DeSean Jackson's in the news for a
ridiculously anti-semitic post that he
put on social media I'm not going to
quote it I don't want to say much about
it I'm just flabbergasted that something
that ridiculously wrong would end up on
social media the question is this what
are the Eagles gonna do about now when
Riley Cooper was videotaped using a slur
back in 2013-14 timeframe early in the
Chip Kelly tenure in Philadelphia they
found a way to move forward which
surprised me because frankly Riley
Cooper wasn't good enough of a player to
justify finding a way to move forward
but they got Mike Vick involved he
smooth things over in the locker room
there were guys like LeSean McCoy who
wanted Riley Cooper out and once the
Eagles were done with Cooper he never
could find footing anywhere else DeSean
Jackson falls into a category right now
in his career where he's not good enough
to justify the trouble and we know this
is how it works for football great
players key players you find a way to
work with them you don't want their
redemption to come with one of your arch
rivals lesser players you make an
example out of them now I think the
right thing to do for this kind of
hatred in this moment for that kind of
ridiculous anti-semitic talk in this
moment the right thing to do is sever
ties regardless of who it is it's an
easier analysis for the Eagles because
it's a guy who's on the downward slope
is it of his career they got nothing out
of him last year although what they got
in week 1 against Washington and I
remember talking to Carson Wentz after
that game
Jackson's abilities the to long
touchdown passes that he scored helped
turn around a game that was going the
wrong way for Philadelphia and until
they know how their rookie first rounder
is gonna work out maybe mitt maybe you
know Jackson's in that bat that no-man's
land between obviously you get rid of
him and obviously you find a way to work
it out with him my preference would be
for this kind of hatred in this moment
that there should be no tolerance for it
and there should be a significant
consequence but the reality is this I I
don't think DeSean Jackson is canceled
there's gonna be somebody out there if
the Eagles move on from DeSean Jackson
once he makes the proper at
and he's already trying taken out of
context misconstrued it's like Charles
Barkley saying he was misquoted in his
own autobiography there's a point where
you can't say that what you said isn't
what you meant to say but at some point
he'll get that second chance especially
this year with the likelihood that
plenty of players will end up on the
kovat 19 list as this virus inevitably
spreads through locker rooms practice
fields game fields etc so that's the
analysis the Eagles have to engage in
and their owners Jewish and their
general managers Jewish and we'll see
how they react to the ridiculously
anti-semitic thoughts that were put on
social media by DeSean Jackson we may do
a second pft p.m. later today with an
update for now the Eagles haven't said
anything
I assume that they'll be saying
something sooner rather than later
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports